I remember in 4th grade everyone had to
bring in a box of tissues I have a
strong memory of that I don't remember
learning too much but I remember I had
to bring in my box of tissues explain
photosynthesis I know what this is I
think it's like when a flower mm-hmm
this is when the sun is shining on
flowers and things and is rain and this
is how things grow plants receive light
from the Sun and they like stay alive
the plant takes in water and sunlight
and through the cell wall and converts
it to energy what are the three branches
of government god I should know that I'm
an adult
Timothy additional legislative Obama
I've been watching a lot of house of
cards but that's not helping there is
the executive branch which is the
president the judicial branch which is
the Supreme Court and then there is the
legislative branch which is the Senate
and Congress the American Civil War when
was it I do not know that's before world
war ii or after I don't think it was
that early 1960s no no it was before
1934 and SLB ocean blue in 1492 he's a
huge [ __ ] film visit the American
Civil War was between 1861 and 1865 what
is xx 3/4 and mixed numeral so that
means this is like how many vodka sodas
I can have in one night divided by the
number of hours it probably takes
further metabolized
seven I feel like I've completely
forgotten how to divide things but
multiplications still there so 4 8 16 20
and then if it were 24 I'd be 5
obviously you know 6 would be 6 2008
yeah right
what is alright I don't wait is this the
mix who knows it's 4 and 3/4 right no
wait that's not right
brunch is $23 divided by 4 people
you finally stumped me with the simple
division that a 4th grader would
definitely know epic 5 but 5 dollars and
10 cents each ok that's the answer kids
[Music]
also just for like kids watching college
is way easier than the 4th grade like
way easier you like talk about your
opinion and then you leave